how are you guys doing for some time
we've been raising funds for this Center
the center in Norway which is meant to
be both a Masjid and dower Center I've
come here to see where your money has
been spent
how are you so much
oh my God
the right place
so first of all we're welcome to this
place
the biggest of this kind yes of its kind
Islamic Center in the country of Norway
yes maybe in Scandinavia so all of this
area here will be the Masjid so we need
to build the mirab over here which is
still the only raising funds for the
prayer carpets Etc yes so this area I
think we could have maybe five six seven
hundred people praying here in Charlotte
yeah that's amazing and Oslo it's a very
expensive city anyway so for you to be
able to establish that with the funds of
these people here that's that's a major
accomplishment isn't it a hundred
percent this is one of the most
expensive cities in Europe it's also the
fastest growing city in Europe even in
the world I think also yeah maybe yeah
could be yes
for all of your kind donations yes with
your donations we've been able to
establish this huge premise and was
still working the construction work will
continue inshallah already you can see
any mashallah what's what's been done so
far it's amazing and when someone does a
prayer here and someone does Salah and
uh and all that stuff people will begin
to do
yes apparently just imagine every single
time someone prays in this Masjid five
times a day the prayer will be will be
established inshallah and you guys would
be getting the reward for that for all
of your kind donations let's go to the
next part yeah
[Laughter]
yeah otherwise this area will be our
main conference Hall this is where you
will be coming and teaching the people
educating them about the dean of Allah
wow and you know what's beautiful is
that I mean you know this the volunteers
have come for the earthquake situation
in turkey and Syria and this is being
made use of this area is being made
useful so you can see here women's
jackets you know men's jackets
three containers have been sent already
to Syria and three containers are being
filled up right now to the center city I
lost amazing people inshallah will be
getting the rules for that as well let's
go ahead and see the next part
facilities let's see is it this way yeah
[Music]
all of this area over here including
this space here and this space here this
will become the voodoo facilities so
obviously we need to rebuild this whole
thing and subhanallah every single time
someone makes blue hair and the droplets
are falling off the sins of the of those
Muslims will be falling off and you guys
yes who have been supporting this
because we'll be getting that wow wow
wow and this is amazing because this is
like as you say it's not just the dial
Center you have a Masjid here so you're
doing all and they're to be honest with
you I'll be honest one of the things I
fear is one day for all dead or canceled
or whatever it may be
will not continue
that's it but by putting money and time
and effort into a place like this
I will continue as the prophet told us
that basically
all of this child of Adam's sins will be
interrupted except for three things and
one of those three things is
a continual charity now this is in
progress isn't it this thing is and
they're doing great work and we're
saying continue doing the great work
we're almost done we're almost done at
least at this section here is going to
be complete uh very soon and we do need
the hard work and donation from you guys
in the persistence and the Doha as well
so make sure make sure to click the link
below and let's make this project a
reality